OK, welcome back.
We're now on problem number
15, and I tried my best to
draw this graph ahead of time.
This is probably one of the more
difficult for me with my
shaky hand.
Let's see what this says.
So this is point O for the
origin right here.
This is point P.
This is point Q.
Then of course this is the
y-axis, this is the x-axis.
And they say that this graph,
right here, is y is equal to a
minus x squared.
And this curve right here is
y is equal to x squared.
So the question says, in the
figure above, the graphs y
equals x squared and y equals
a minus x squared for some
constant a-- oh, those
are the graphs.
Right.
If the length of PQ is equal to
6, what is the value of a?
Well, it's interesting.
So the first thing that should
jump out at you is that these
are completely symmetric
graphs, right?
They both are kind
of mirror images
around the y-axis, right?
So if this length is 6, then the
length of each of these--
then here is 3 and here is 3.
Right?
So what do we know about where
these graphs intersect?
Well, we know that they
intersect at the point 3, and
we know that they intersect as
well at the point minus 3.
Those are where those two
graphs intersect.
And that's a lot
of information.
And the way, once again, we came
to this conclusion was
that these are both symmetric
around the y-axis.
So if this intersection
is 6 wide, soon. then
it's 3 on each side.
Right?
3 at the positive side, 3
at the negative side.
So it intersects at x equals
3 and x equals minus 3.
And if we want to figure out the
intersection, we can also
just set these two equal to
each other. y equals x
squared, y equals a
minus x squared.
So we know that x squared must
be equal to a minus-- what am
I doing? a minus x squared.
Or add x squared to both
sides of this equation.
You get 2x squared
is equal to a.
Right?
And this'll be true at the two
points, at the two x points,
where these two graphs
intersect.
Well, what are the x points?
We figured that out.
It's 3 and minus 3.
So if you put 3 in here,
you get 2 times 3
squared is equal to a.
It's 2 times 9 is equal to a.
a is equal to 18.
And if you put minus 3 in here,
it'd be the same thing,
because when you square it
the negative goes away.
So a is 18.
Not too bad.
The key conclusion you have to
make is that they intersect at
the points positive
and negative 3.
And then you just set the
equations equal to each other
and solve for a.
Let's do the next problem.
Clear image.
Set X has x members, and
set Y has y members.
Set Z contains all the members
that are either in X or Y,
with the exception of the
k common members.
OK, so this sounds like
a Venn diagram.
I don't know if you remember a
Venn diagram, but I'll show
you what one is.
So let's say that
this is set X.
And let's say that this
is set Y right here.
Looks like a MasterCard
logo. you
So this is set Y,
this is set X.
And it says, set Z consists of
all the members that are
either in set X or set Y,
with the exception of
the k common members.
So this is the k common
members, right?
These are the things that
overlap with set X and set Y.
So what does Z consist of?
Well, Z is going to be-- let
me pick a dark color.
Z is going to be-- if I do the
fill tool-- it's going to be
that plus that.
Right?
Without the k, right?
Because it says Z does not
include the overlap.
So what are those two things?
Let me go back to
the paint tool.
Orange.
It's going to be tacky with
all the colors I'm using.
So there's x members
in all of X.
x members in all of capital X.
So how many members are
in this blue region?
So if there's x in the whole
region, there's going to be x
minus k in this blue
region, right?
I just subtracted
out this k part.
Similarly, Y has y members,
as the problem tells us.
Capital Y set has lowercase
y members.
But if we take out these k that
overlap, this is going to
be y minus k.
I'm just subtracting it out.
And so Z is this blue area
plus this blue area.
So it'll be x minus
k plus y minus k.
And that is equal to x plus y.
We have two minus k's,
so it's minus 2k.
And that is choice D.
Not too bad, huh?
All right.
I think we are all done with
this practice test. Hopefully
you found it vaguely useful.
I'll see